[Musique]
attention
non seulement sur le serpent et c'est
l'amant l'état immédiate inquiète
j'ai toujours une arme sur moi si les
cours de musique servait vraiment
[Musique]
ça a marché
bon on va pas moisir ici en voici le
topo
un contact a réussi à me faire passer le
matos de son fils pour qu'on puisse
élaborer un plan de sortie si les cours
de maths servait vraiment gtno pattinson
ça m'étonnerait que nous arrivions à
sortir de ces prisons avec ce matériel à
moins que
à monsieur le président je vous présente
mcguire mon meilleur conseiller
mcguire nous avons reçu un mail cryptée
très étrange
je dois en effet une copie ça sent
mauvais perso et que c'est un coup des
russes plus triste fait pas rentrer en
guerre contre ce pays
si les cours de latin servait vraiment
attendu curé écuries curie le
déroulement vita est vital la vie
[Musique]
c'est un curriculum vitae cv aucun
danger
du coup on se fait un don mc trésor du
pharaon a bon dos vi a roulé à temps qui
nous dit qu'il n'est pas maudit
regarde une inscription sur look mars je
ne vois plus rien si les cours de techno
servait vraiment inquiète pas j'ai
toujours mon porte clés lumineux
j'ai roulé quoi vous allez vous en
sortir comme ça 5 la semaine les cours
de français servait vraiment ces jeunes
agence fédérale a effectué une faute de
français vous ne pouvez pas dire vous
croyez que vous devez dire vous avez cru
que ou alors pas parfait vous croyez que
par voie de fait votre ordre est
irrecevable par mon collègue et moi même
je dis par votre femme dieu alors c'est
qu'on a gagné monsieur le président nous
avons trouvé ce que vous nous avez
demandé si c'est bien ce que je pense
que tu président la russie ne posera
plus aucun problème surtout pas [ __ ]
merde ils surviennent ont enfin trouvé
le moyen d'indiquer si les cours de
physique-chimie serveuse roman attendait
regardez monsieur président on a ici 12
solution mais une basique l'autre acide
à l'aide d'un indicateur coloré
on pourrait obtenir leur ph et
introduire une substance complémentaires
qui nous permettrait d'annuler la
réaction c'est vrai mais ce n'est pas
tout vous voyez cette architecture
électrique
et bien c'est un circuit en séries si je
place une résistance en dérivation pour
affaiblir la sécurité et accéder aux
liquides
j'ai justement un multimètre sous la
main si je place le curseur survolt je
pourrai alors calculer la tension sont
clés pour circuit et ce en moins de 30
secondes ce qui nous permettrait
désamorcer la bombe
incroyable qu'elle s'est encore une fois
grâce à votre talent c'est pas
aujourd'hui qu'on la crap
n'hésite pas à ta bonne et à la chaîne
golden moustache et aussi à cliquer sur
la bombe pour voir le making-of pense
aussi à re lire tes cours d'svt car on
n'est jamais à l'abri d'un petit
contrôle surprise bien vicieux tu peux
aussi regarder un ancien sketch golden
moustache mais garde un petit peu de
temps pour les bété tu sais j'ai un
mauvais pressentiment je ne les sens pas
cette année